et nous sommes avec stéphane menigoz
porte parole du goût du mouvement
restons ouverts également frédéric
leturque merck sont tristes d'arras
également avec nos arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire bonsoir messieurs merci
à tous les trois d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on l'aura
compris évidemment le gouvernement qui
tente de reprendre la main conseil de
défense conseil des ministres ce matin
au menu la campagne de vaccination très
critiqué à sa sortie le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a fait un
point sur l'accélération de cette
campagne écouter les vaccins continuent
à arriver sur notre sol nous en aurons
ce soir un total d'un million de doses
et nous recevrons 500 mille doses
supplémentaires par semaine
pour ce qui est du vaccin fader by one
tech j'ajoute que le l'agencé européenne
du médicament a rendu sa décision sur
l'autorisation du vaccin moderna et vous
le savez la haute autorité de santé
rendra son avis très rapidement ce qui
nous permettra également d'être
approvisionné pour ce vaccin à raison de
200 mille doses sur le premier mois puis
de 500 mille doses par mois alors un
propos plutôt optimistes de la part du
porte parole de gouvernement c'est de
nature à rassurer frédéric leturque
je pense que de toute façon il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on se sent tous mobilisés
est tous concerné par cette séquence de
vaccination elle n'est pas simple à
mettre en place parce que pour vacciner
il faut avoir les doses de vaccin
suffisante et c'était peut-être un peu
le sujet qui était plus ou moins pas
avoué par le gouvernement s'était cette
difficulté peut-être d'être fournies en
nombre suffisant de vaccins puisque
kaiser on le sait en fait n'avait
peut-être pas capacité totalement à
satisfaire l'ensemble du spectre que
l'on voulait couvrir aujourd'hui les
choses sont claires le fait que modern a
en fait soit en quelque sorte un peu
libérez ouvre un espoir supplémentaire
de développer l'organisation de la
vaccination dans les territoires et je
vous parle en fait ici de l'hôpital
d'arras où j'étais au cours des deux
dernières heures en en point avec
l'ensemble des élus du territoire de
l'artois du bassin minier du douaisis du
ternois et du bal qu'à moi en fait
qu'ils sont les territoires autour
desquels en fait que l'hôpital d'arras
est amenée en fait à organiser en
quelque sorte la distribution des doses
ces doses sont arrivés hier ici arras et
le process de vaccination est en marche
les vaccinations se sont bien déroulées
aujourd'hui et et nous avançons et nous
sommes même prêts puisque je suis
président des maires du pas de calais et
je coordonne aussi des associations des
maires de la raison des hôtes des hauts
de france en fait en tant qu'élu à à
mettre les les outils qu'il faut en fait
pour déployer des centres de vaccination
dans les territoires
parce qu'aujourd'hui en fait c'est ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens voilà et
mais on ne peut pas en fait organiser
les centres aussi les vaccins ne sont
pas là ce qui a été dit par le le porte
parole du gouvernement aujourd'hui est
rassurant et correspond à toutes les
discussions en fait très clair que j'ai
pu avoir
y compris avec olivier ferrand que je
s'est engagée sur le sujet et qui je
l'espère en tout cas va nous permettre
dans l'est dans les prochaines semaines
de pouvoir en fait accélérer le
mouvement en sec de toute façon process
de vaccination est quelque chose qui va
mettre du temps à gérer que ça sert à
rien de raconter des choses qui seraient
qui serait fausse alors organise
vaccination à l'échelle de la france à
l'échelle d'un pays en fait mais du
temps voilà et on peut pas faire un an
puisse dire effectivement un frédéric
leturque à on met du temps les chiffres
le disent pour nous c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de moqueries
voilà sur les réseaux sociaux on
on entend certains experts dire que la
france est la risée du monde en tout cas
vous faites partie de ces 250 maires qui
ont proposé de se faire vacciner pour
montrer l'exemple
malgré les promesses on a le sentiment
que la logistique justement vous en
parliez pêche c'est aussi le sentiment
du professeur akon qui était notre
invitée hier soir écouter à partir du
moment où on a décidé de vacciner dans
les ehpad
on a complètement oublié que dans les
ehpad y avait des personnes qui
n'avaient plus toutes leurs capacités
intellectuelles et que donc il fallait
me prendre contact avec des tuteurs pour
pouvoir obtenir le consentement et ça ça
n'avait pas été anticipée apparemment
donc effectivement il ya une perte de
temps alors je m'adresse aux
communicants nos benedetti on voit que
le gouvernement voilà mais le met le
turbo si j'ose dire et tente de
reprendre la main il faut préciser quand
même que 75% des français selon un
sondage et lab juge que cette
organisation de campagne de vaccination
est très mal gérée par le gouvernement
il est en train justement de récupérer
la main ce gouvernement où ça va mettre
du temps selon vous cela met du temps
mais si vous voulez aujourd'hui
l'exécutif à changer de discours et
vraisemblablement également changé de
stratégie parce que tout simplement il y
a eu une pression médiatique politique
et une pression de l'opinion pour que il
change de stratégie je rappelle qu' il y
a encore ou au moins d'une dizaine de
jours le ministre de la santé où olivier
vais en assumer une stratégie de la
lenteur alors il faut s'expliquer
expliqué et c'est comprendre pourquoi
cette stratégie initiale a été déployé
alors elle a peut-être été déployés par
ce que il y avait vraisemblablement une
insuffisance logistique
d'ailleurs cette crise sanitaire est en
train de démontrer que l'état
en tout cas au cou à l'épreuve de cette
pandémie apparaît comme un piètre
logisticiens mais aussi parce que il y
avait vraisemblablement de la part des
pouvoirs publics et des autorités
politiques les des autorités sanitaires
la crainte que la défiance qui
aujourd'hui est manifeste qu'on me
montre un certain nombre d'études
d'opinion vis-à-vis des sondages que
cette défiance viennent d'une certaine
manière entraver la campagne de
vaccination donc le choix qui a été fait
au niveau du discours qui à mon avis est
une erreur en l'occurrence et
d'intérioriser cette défiance et de
mettre en place ensuite une stratégie
qui était une stratégie initialement
d'un déploiement qui était un
déploiement qui se faisait à petite
vitesse
là en l'occurrence la pression
d'opinions publiques la pression des
médias et la pression politique a
certainement aujourd'hui fait en sorte
que le gouvernement change de fusil
départ lui entre temps le retard a été
pris et ils valent quand même difficile
à rattraper et la réalité c'est que la
comparaison avec eux l'ensemble de nos
partenaires européens et dans d'autres
d'autres pays montrent aujourd'hui que
la france est quand même en retard et on
peut se poser la question si vous voulez
s'il ya eu un véritable retour
d'expérience depuis le début de cette
crise on a raté des masques on n'a pas
vraiment réussi les tests et là en
l'occurrence on avait quand même malgré
tout l'expérience de cet échec et on
peut se poser la question si on s'est
mis véritablement en ordre de marche
pour démarrer une campagne de
vaccination qui évite en effet cette
controverse supplémentaires à l'exécutif
qui est dans la vie par besoin dans la
gestion de cette crise
stéphane manigold on va évidemment
évoqué avec vous forcément le sort des
des restaurateurs qui seront fixés sur
j'ai envie de dire leur triste sort
certainement demain mais je voulais voir
votre opinion citoyen justement sur ce
vaccin le gouvernement effectivement
vous avez le sentiment vous aussi il a
péché par excès de prudence pour ne pas
heurter pour ne pas braquer les anti
vaccins nombreux en france
bonsoir je vais pas vous donner mon
opinion citoyens puisque je porte la
parole d'un collectif qui s'appelle
restons ouverts et je tiens à vous
féliciter arte france parce que vous
avez trouvé le seul homme politique en
france capable de défendre l'idée
verrons bravo monsieur le maire d'arras
jeu
ce beau discours il aimait mes lunaire
olivier ferrand aujourd'hui il est le
responsable
l'unique responsable de la politique de
santé chaotique de ce pays ce pays ça
fait neuf mois qu'il est fermé
contat tonnes qu'on va à reculons que
des entreprises sont massacrés parce que
nous avons un type olivier ferrand
ministre de la santé qui a en charge la
sécurité des français qui la semaine
dernière nous explique avec une
expression d'un autre temps
faut pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation une fois qui s'est pris un
sacré coup de pied au derrière de la
part du président de la république et
les raisons il y va maintenant va
accélérer
monsieur le maire vous avez reçu combien
de vaccins dans votre ville d'arras qui
regroupe quoi 41 mille habitants 0e
commun de vaccins plus décomptés combien
de vaccins vous ai reçu aucun pourquoi
vous pourquoi vous venez dire vous avez
reçu des vaccins
c'est l'arlésienne nous on a besoin et
cette campagne de vaccination sur
l'efficace et je veux dire une chose
moi je le dis depuis deux jours
maintenant olivier vers ans doit quitter
le gouvernement
il n'est plus le général en chef il ne
peut plus être à la tête de ce pays
parce qu'en réalité c'est lui qui
gouverne c'est lui qui dirige et c'est
lui qui nous ferme c'est le code de
santé publique qui lui donne ses
pouvoirs c'est lui qui a le pouvoir de
police d'ouvrir 2 fermée de restreindre
nos libertés de tout faire en réalité
c'est lui qui décide de tout et vu qu'il
est incapable et que nous on n'a pas
envie de suivre en général qui ne sait
pas assumer qui n'a pas de colonne
vertébrale parce que nous on est des
chefs d'entreprise et quand on donne un
cap à une entreprise on le maintient on
c'est l'orienter et on est un vrai chef
il n'est pas un chef de guerre il doit
quitter le gouvernement je suis désolé
monsieur le maire je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous la population dans sa
large majorité n'est pas d'accord avec
vous et franchement venir défendre sur
ce plateau olivier ferrand qui est une
politique catastrophique
c'est insupportable et inaudible fait
mais nicole tout de même c'est justement
ce qui est intéressant c'est de donner
la parole à tout le monde et c'est bien
l'essence de notre chaîne donc on est
ravis nous d'entendre toutes les
opinions on va justement laisser la
parole à frédéric leturque un frédéric
leturque c'est justement
tout sur vers ans ou peut-être aussi on
a beaucoup évoqué ces derniers jours la
lourdeur administrative structurelles
finalement à notre pays qui pêchent dans
cette affaire écoutez je suis maire
d'arras je suis président d'une
communauté urbaine je suis président de
l'association des maires du département
du pas de calais et je peux vous dire
monsieur contrairement à ce que vous
dites que ben nous avons reçu les
vaccins que de la vaccination il en
place 4875 les coups du sort fête 4875
plus en fait
4875 dans la commune de calais qui est
aussi en fait
détenteur d'un hôpital socle pour son
secteur +4 1875 à amiens qui couvre en
fait un autre secteur et je peux vous
dire que le département du pas de calais
aujourd'hui à organiser en fait des
lieux de vaccination pour les personnes
âgées pour les soignants pour les
personnels à risque et que les choses en
fait se met en place
dirais que c'est facile de crier sur un
plateau en fait toute sa colère et je
comprends que vous soyez
finalement entre les fils monsieur mais
ça fait neuf mois
non monsieur je pense que vous ne
mesurez peut-être pas en fait que le
contexte il n'est pas simplement due en
fait à une personnalité politique mais
il est mondial que la problématique du
coc vide en fait elle est certainement
plus complexes à traiter en fait que de
gérer
excusez la vacciner en israël plus de 4
millions aux états unis
c'est bien le chef de guerre qui pilote
la politique de vaccination ce truc pays
moi je ne suis pas venu en fait
peut-être télévision pour jouer au
tennis je préside ici un conseil de
surveillance d'hôpital j'ai animé en
fait de réunion juste avant de vous
rejoindre ici avec des soignants avec
des gens qui ont travaillé toute la
journée qui ont organisé les choses qui
ont vacciné avec des présidents de
centres hospitaliers des directeurs en
fait qui ont mis en place les mêmes
centres de vaccination dans le
territoire vous avez le droit de dire en
fait que ce que je dis n'est pas
vraiment tout état de cause en tant que
président de conseil de surveillance
qu'on place voilà dans une partie tennis
ya un arbitre arnaud benedetti est ce
que vous avez envie de jouer sept
arbitres quel est justement le regard
que vous portez sur la responsabilité
éventuellement du ministre de la santé
ce système évidemment on parle de la
louve administrative le disais quel est
votre sentiment là-dessus
non mais je le m'autoriserai surtout pas
être l'arbitré je n'ai pas la prétention
mais en l'occurrence ce qui est vrai
c'est que le sentiment qui se dégage
maintenant depuis encore une fois le
début de cette crise sanitaire et de
manière encore plus forte et j'allais
dire avec plus d'acuité
avec le démarrage de cette campagne de
vaccination c'est que on a un état et
une administration qui manque d'agilité
ça a été relevé à plusieurs reprises le
problème le problème c'est que dans une
démocratie ce sont les politiques qui
décident et que si les politiques n'ont
pas pris le pouvoir sur l'administration
c'est qu'il y a manifestement un
problème je rappelle quand même qu
emmanuel macron s'est fait élire sur une
promesse de réformes et notamment de
réforme de l'état en l'occurrence on ce
qu on constate on est obligé de
constater que finalement il n'y a rien
de nouveau sous le soleil
on a en france une conception de l'état
sanitaire qui était une conception
d'excellence c'était un de nos derniers
domaines d'excellence et ce qui vraiment
aujourd'hui choc une partie de l'opinion
publique je veux bien que la comparaison
avec l'international soit en effet
permettent de relativiser ce qui se
passe en france mais quand on se compare
aujourd'hui ne serait ce que sur le
ratio qui à mon avis le ratio le plus
essentiel c'est à dire le ratio des ces
populations malheureusement on est dans
le haut des pays qui paye le plus lourd
tribut à cette épidémie donc ça veut
dire concrètement qu'il ya quelque chose
qui n'a pas fonctionné
en l'occurrence donc on ne peut pas
totalement absoudre on regarde une
situation qui était ce qui est une
situation internationale la
responsabilité politique de l'exécutif
du ministre de la santé bien évidemment
de son administration également mais
aussi du président de la république
parce que je veux bien que le président
de la république et admonesté monsieur v
rang lors du dernier conseil de défense
qui s'est déroulé
avant dernier conseil de défense mais en
l'occurrence sous la vème république
c'est le président de la république qui
est responsable et c'est lui qui doit
s'assurer aussi d'une certaine manière
il nous a dit qu'on était en guerre qui
doit s'assurer en tant que chef de
guerre que la tendance est à la mesure
des moyens étaient à la mesure notamment
de l'épreuve que l'on traverse donc on
ne peut pas si vous voulez mettre tout
sur le dos de l'administration
l'administration et responsable bien
évidemment mais le premier responsable
dans un système politique est un système
politique démocratique c'est le
politique et c'est l'honneur du
politique de pouvoir justement être
responsable et de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse répondre à la crise en tout
cas les présidents de région souvent
montent au créneau jean rottner on a
beaucoup cité qui parlait d'un scandale
d'état précédent dans la région grand
est hervé morin en normandie veut
acheter ses propres dose de masse de
vaccins xavier bertrand pour la région
et aux transfuges qui fustige la lenteur
vaccinale et le manque de transparence
propose les écouter il faut vacciner le
plus massivement et le plus rapidement
possible je suis en discussions avec un
laboratoire pour faire en sorte que
lorsqu'il y aura plus de vaccins
produits à travers le monde que nous
puissions nous région acheter des
vaccins pour que tous ceux qui vont
bosser le matin puisse être vaccinés
qu'on nous démontre études scientifiques
à l'appui que même avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée on ne peut pas
rouvrir les restaurants mais alors
pourquoi les cantines scolaires et les
restaurants d'entreprises restent
ouverts ce deux poids deux mesures est
incompréhensible alors là stéphane
manigold xavier bertrand qui met de
l'eau à votre moulin j'imagine bien sûr
les présidents de région ils sont
évidemment choqués par la gestion de et
on leur grande majorité sont choqués par
ces gestion de crise par cette espèce de
stigmatisation je rappelle quand même à
monsieur le maire d'arras que les
restaurants y compris d'arras ont fermé
depuis trois mois avec le virus continue
à circuler et on parle même d'une
troisième vague qui sera bien plus
importante que la première la deuxième
je vais juste répondre sur la
responsabilité politique
lorsque l'on charge nos fonctionnaires
je suis désolé vous avez deux généraux
aujourd'hui je vais prendre ces exemples
vous avez
veron et vous avez vous nous le maire
véran à la santé catastrophique nous
inexistant bruno le maire offensif
proche des entreprises et sur tous les
terrains avec alain griset sur les pme
l'artisanat et le commerce
donc je suis désolé monsieur le maire de
vous le dire c'est bien une question
politique c'est aux politiques de donner
de l'élan son administration est
certainement pas l'administration qui
doit donner de l'élan politique c'est
pas comme ça qu'on conçoit une
entreprise en tout cas dans une
entreprise si le chef d'entreprise se
fait donner d en-bas ses salariés c'est
qu'un problème et je suis sûr que dans
votre mairie monsieur le maire en tout
cas j'espère c'est vous qui donner de
l'élan au conseil municipal à vos
adjoints et hauts fonctionnaires
municipaux et c'est certainement pas les
fonctionnaires municipaux en tout cas je
l'espère qui vont vous donner
l'impulsion pour organiser la politique
de vaccination tels que vous venez de la
décrire alors en tout cas ces politiques
ils vont s'exprimer 1 demain jean castex
en tête grande conférence de presse
doit-on s'attendre frédéric leturque à
un nouveau tour de vis que vous en tant
que maire justement vous le souhaitez
par nécessité entre guillemets alors
trois choses la première je le redis
pour votre interlocuteur je ne suis pas
là pour faire le procès ni du président
ni du ministre veron ou de quelques
ministres que ce soit moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de jouer collectif
c'est de faire mon travail et donc âgées
excusez moi c'est d'engager en fait un
mouvement de travail et d'efforts qui
fasse que dans un contexte de guerre est
une priorité en fête nationale on soit
mobilisée et je peux vous dire que ici
dans le territoire
je suis hyper mobilisé y compris auprès
des professions que vous représentez et
auprès desquels je suis tous les jours
et on a mis en place des dispositions de
soutien dead et on met en place les
dispositions d'accompagnement et
d'espoir pour la réouverture qui seront
aussi efficace dans ce territoire
qu'ailleurs parce que on se sent tous
concernés par cette situation
deuxième chose oui j'espère en fait
qu'il y aura des des conditions en fait
de gérer de d'accélération de cette
séquence de vaccination qui se met en
place c'est la vaccination qui
m'intéresse pas des mesures
en fait tu irais de fermetures
supplémentaires qui viennent en quelque
sorte encore accentué ce côté anxiogène
et désespérant dans lequel en fait on
est placé depuis sept années 2020 donc
je n'attends pas en fait des mesures
supplémentaires de fermeture ou ou des
couvre-feux en fait dans d'autres
départements tout cas c'est parce que
j'espère j'espère plutôt linverse mais
il est il est clair en fait que
malheureusement dans un tel contexte que
ce que je vois dans certains
départements de l'est m'attriste et que
je préfère en fait être en mode combat
comme je le suis ici dans le département
du pas de calais pour essayer d'éviter à
ce que quelque part on ne sombre dans ce
type de sujet et pour répondre à votre
troisième interlocuteur je suis d'accord
avec lui sur un point c'est qu'il faudra
tirer les leçons de ce que l'on vit en
fait depuis le début de l'année 2020
avec cette séquence du coc vide et qu'on
cuisse en fait mettre noir sur blanc ce
que l'on a vécu noir sur blanc ce qui a
fonctionné ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
parce que en fait je suis convaincu que
demain on vivra peut-être d'autres
séquences qui seront aussi compliqué et
qu'il faudra qu'on soit en mode combat
un peu plus efficace un peu plus rapide
un peu plus agile un peu plus
opérationnel mais de grâce essayons de
respecter celles et ceux qui sont debout
au travail
je peux vous dire qu'ici je suis
entourée d'hommes et de femmes de
médecins qui donnent le maximum pour
soigner et pour essayer de faire que
nous soyons tous finalement aux
capacités de faire notre travail
là nous sommes dans le public elle doit
même propos monsieur le maire on sait
très bien que les élus locaux
c'est très bien que les élus locaux les
élus de proximité
les maires les présidents de région font
un travail exceptionnel
mes propos c'était pas vous concernant
c'était concernant le ministre vers ans
et pourquoi aujourd'hui nous les chefs
pour trouver ce qu'on va t on va donner
allez-y très rapidement s'il vous plaît
parce que nous fait notre succès ses
fans manigold le mot de voilà rapidement
vous terminez votre propre au hilton le
mot de la fin
visiblement la vaccine pour que la
vaccination soit efficace ces six
semaines
il est urgent que le chef de guerre le
général qui s'occupe de la vie
six nations soit efficace à l'évidence
il ne l'est pas a renouvellé d'etihad
doit à quoi doit-on s'attendre justement
demain en mode combat comme le disait
frédéric leturque nouveau tour de vis je
ne sais pas s'il faut s'attendre à un
nouveau tour de vis la question est de
savoir si aujourd'hui et l'opinion
publique est prête et notamment les
acteurs économiques et je pense ans
restaurateur entre entrée au milieu
culturel le centre est véritablement à
supporter encore durant des semaines et
des semaines ce qui constitue pour eux
une catastrophe économique et sociale
donc en effet on va bien voir en
fonction de la vitesse de circulation du
virus ce qui va être décidé par
l'exécutif mais il y a une vraie course
de vitesse aujourd'hui qui est engagée
parce que il y a une profonde lassitude
aujourd'hui qui est en train de
s'exprimer à la fois dans l'opinion
publique et certains noms d'acteurs
économiques sociaux culturels et il est
évident que l'équipe qu'il doit répondre
très rapidement et ne plus disons se
cacher derrière des dysfonctionnements
qui serait ce son administration en
l'occurrence il faut qu'il reprenne la
main sur son administration qu'il aille
très vite et qui répondent surtout aux
problèmes logistiques parce que
aujourd'hui quand même la question
essentielle c'est de savoir est ce que
les doses de vaccins qui sont annoncés
seront bien là dans les jours qui
viennent parce que sur les chiffres
quand même
faut-il le rappeler depuis un certain
nombre de semaines on a eu des annonces
qui ont toujours été infirmée par les
ché merci en tout cas tous les trois
messieurs stéphane manigold frédéric
leturque et arnaud benedetti d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce débat ce décryptage